So there is a taxonomy called
Flynn's Taxonomy of Parallel Machines.
It distinguishes parallel machines
according to how many instruction
streams they have and how many data
streams these instructions operate on.
The first type of machine is single
instruction, single data, or SISD,
and logically this type of machine
executes one instruction stream,
and each instruction
operates on one data stream.
This is really your normal uniprocessor.
So if we have for example, a single
core machine, that's what it is.
The next type of machine is single
instruction, multiple data.
So it executes one instruction stream,
meaning there is one program with
a single program counter we go through,
but there is more than one
data stream they operate on.
The most common example of this used
to be so-called vector processors,
which execute a program.
But each instruction, instead of
operating on normal scalar values,
operates on vectors.
So, for example,
you can execute an ad instruction, but
it operates on two source and
one destination vector of things.
So it operates on many many
data items at the time.
Modern processors also have this
multimedia extension instruction,
such as MMX or SSE 1, 2, 3, and
they're also an example of limited SIMD.
Where a single multimedia instruction
will operate on maybe four or
eight data items.
Then you can have a multiple
instruction single data stream.
This is weird, because we have
multiple instruction streams.
So there are several different
programs executing at the same time,
all operating on
the same stream of data.
So it's not used much and
the closest we get to this is
something like a stream processor.
Where you have the first processor
operating on, for example,
the raw data from the camera,
and then that data moves on to
the next processor which is
going to process it some further.
Like find the edges, or sharpen it,
or something and so on.
But even there, it's not truly that
we have a single data stream, because
the output of the first processor is
not the same as the raw camera feed.
So this is just kind of
the closest we get to it, but
really, MISD is not really used much.
And then we have MIMD, where there is
more than one instruction stream and
more than one data stream.
And this would be your normal
multiprocessor where each processor has
its own program that it's running with
its own program counter and zone, and
each of them operates on its own data.
So they don't have to do things in
lock step to operate on the data, and
they don't do something
like a stream processing.
So this type of processor really
includes most of the processors you can
buy today because most
processors today are multi-core,
which means really they have
several processor cores.
Each of which executes it's
own instruction stream and
can access data independently,
so it has multiple data streams.
And this lesson is mostly
about this type of machines.